ladies and gentlemen let's bring the
stage the funniest [ __ ] I know
the one and only hilarious Joey Diaz one
more time for my man Tom Segura one more
time the Argentinian I [ __ ] love it
I'm it's hysterical nice to live in
Hollywood I didn't see nobody you can
see [ __ ] you know whatever these
creepy people but you don't really
understand like one two you like I moved
to North Hollywood now I understand the
Mexican Cuban but I never understood the
Mexican like till it's [ __ ] all the
way to the roof you understand me and
you talk to people by mixing what they
tell you brother here to take off for
Punjab no they're not here to make your
life easier
okay tonight you look like a [ __ ] up
you're gonna need some [ __ ] you know
I'm Sam you're gonna wake up you don't
wake up with a headache and hair in your
throat this shit's gonna be missing you
know it's [ __ ] Sunday if you're a
real [ __ ] tonight that's how it
is tomorrow morning you wake up there's
a stranger next to you you got condoms
everywhere a knife and you pop inside
you can't breathe you're thirsty and
[ __ ]
you washed your face you're brushing you
need something to drink
right so right away you want to get like
the nourishment back so you're driving
on vent or over the [ __ ] you live and
you see Jamba Juice and I gotta cut
somebody off and go in there wait some
guy comes out with 22 Jamba Juice's and
you gotta [ __ ] you know the whole
thing then you know and then it's done
ate this I supposed to be a healthy
place everybody's [ __ ] pale do like
the cast and Twilight they're all
[ __ ] skinny and [ __ ] hi can I help
you I just want something drink [ __ ] I'm
saying I want some vitamins for 50
Cent's we got vitamin D how much $12
$12,000 you give they got a ticket you
gotta all right with a blender you gotta
wait eight more [ __ ] minutes you're
almost dead gonna give me the [ __ ]
thing and you're drinking you are you
got a $92 [ __ ] ticket cuz you can't
park there from 10 to something one okay
so it cost you hundred dollars for a
[ __ ] gyro whatever the [ __ ] it is
Jamba Juice you know with the castor
Twilight a bunch of unhealthy skinny
[ __ ] that living on 5-hour
energy and other [ __ ] nutrients eat
[ __ ] you wanna juice they're back there
texting like a bunch of [ __ ] Momo's
on their iPhone I don't got an iPhone I
got a gun [ __ ] you understand
you're my [ __ ] Jamba Juice Oh
or or you go to the Mexican guy on
victory and violent right by target
right there you go to that mother clock
that that's [ __ ] do these dark cuz
he's been out there for years you
understand me
they're in a tree out there this
[ __ ] heart you know he's black
what the [ __ ] dog
you're gonna par just pull right there
[ __ ] you can double bark with your ass
sticking out of the target they don't
give a [ __ ] you go out there you like
listen brah [ __ ] up I want some of the
drinking those coconuts he'll take one
I'm coconuts out and taking Miceli out
right there on victory and violent by
our way
put the [ __ ] show on it with some
cocaine on the top of it [ __ ] you're
like how much for hours for dollars take
10 you got a sword [ __ ] four
thousand dollars I can drop a hundred
and Jamba Juice for four hours it's
Mexico give me a tree a shovel a [ __ ]
lawnmower and a [ __ ] thing a Jamba
Papaji the [ __ ]
you